the moral presuppositions of a culture
are instantiated in its stories they're
not instantiated in its explicit
philosophy there might be a layer of
explicit philosophy and of course there
is in the west and a layer of explicit
law but underneath that there are
stories and there isn't anything under
the stories except maybe behavior you
know and that's so implicit it doesn't
even actually count it's not a cognitive
operation and so this is the story these
are the stories that are underneath our
culture and so there better be something
to them that's what we hope and but more
importantly maybe we shouldn't toss them
away without knowing what they mean
because if we toss them away then we're
throwing everything that we depend on
away as far as I can tell and we will
pay for it we'll pay for it individually
because we'll be weak you know because
if you're not firm in your convictions
then someone else who's firm in their
convictions can you're their puppet like
instantly and then you're also the
puppet of your own doubts right because
unless you have convictions
you're gonna generate doubts like mad
because everyone does and then the
doubts win and and you'll be paralyzed
because there'll be you know 50% of you
moving forward and 50% of you frozen
stiff and that'll be enough just to
lodge you in place and so ok so there's
a psychologize ation of the idea of
leadership which is very important and
then it's associated with the idea of
character or logical development and
it's associated with the idea of
struggle not happiness and it's also
associated with this Abrahamic idea
which I really liked and which was
something that's been very useful to me
as a consequence of doing these lectures
because remember at the beginning of the
Abrahamic stories abraham's like a
stay-at-home guy right he's like the guy
who's 40 years old living in his in his
in his mother's basement and god says
like get the hell out of there you know
get out in the world where you belong go
do something difficult because what
you're doing isn't acceptable and you
know the first thing he does is go
somewhere there's a terrible famine and
then he goes somewhere there's a tyranny
so you know it's it's pretty funny he
follows God's call and it's not like
sweetness and light and paradise
immediately it's nothing like that it's
it's instantaneous combat you know
the most difficult time